you know growing up i had the worst
teeth i had cavities and every single
tooth i was always at the dentist the
only thing good about the dentist is
they would give you a lollipop and i
really wish i would have known what i
know now back then because it could have
saved me a lot of problems with my teeth
but i want to share with you the best
two
foods that you should be eating for your
teeth now you can skip forward to get
right to those two foods but i want to
first talk about why you should consume
these two foods
the first thing is
vitamin a in relationship to your teeth
and gums okay vitamin a supports a lot
of things but it's especially important
in the internal skin and mucous
membranes of your body especially the
gums
and vitamin a increases the resistance
to infection of the mucous membranes so
if you're deficient in vitamin a you're
much more susceptible to getting an
infection especially of the gums and
there is a condition called pyrea which
is basically gum disease that occurs
when you're vitamin a deficient
and so there's various degrees of gum
problems
it starts out with inflammation of the
gums called gingivitis and then it can
progress into something more serious
called
periodontitis which involves more
complications with the gums redness
chronic halitosis bad breath
infection plaquing things like that one
thing you should know about the plaque
on your teeth or tartar
that's not just bacteria that is also
candida a type of fungus that can grow
so in your mouth you have friendly
bacteria and you have friendly yeast or
fungus that hacks that keep everything
in check it's only when things get out
of balance
that you start developing an overgrowth
of yeast and fungus and bacteria and
that can develop tartar and plaque and
the byproduct of those guys is acids
that then create
cavities now of course the thing that
starts the whole thing
is the fuel that you're feeding these
these pathogens and that would be sugar
so people that have
high sugar in the diet or carbohydrates
have a lot more of the unfriendly
bacteria in their mouth that create the
cavities and so this data between
sugar and cavities was suppressed in the
early 70s
there's some really interesting data i
will share down below so instead they
shifted their attention on saturated
fats and away from sugar but out of all
the foods you should avoid for your
teeth and gums sugar is at the top of
the list so vitamin a is really really
important with your your gums
now if you have
periodontitis okay
and you have enough vitamin c
you probably retain your
teeth okay you're not going to lose your
teeth and you probably won't have as
much bleeding but if you actually
combine a vitamin c deficiency
you'll tend to get loose teeth or you'll
lose a tooth and you'll have bleeding so
in scurvy for example which is a severe
vitamin c deficiency one indication of a
vitamin c deficiency would be bleeding
gums because of what vitamin c does to
your connective tissue and it keeps the
capillaries from leaking blood so
vitamin c is very important in keeping
the connective tissue especially of your
gums really nice and tight and strong as
well as building up your resistance to
infection
so as you know vitamin c is important in
your immune system then we have vitamin
b1 now the reason i'm bringing this up
is because if you have a tooth that's
hurting
you have like some nerve involvement
okay neuritis and vitamin b1 is the best
remedy for any type of itis or
inflammation of the nerve so taking b1
can help a toothache now of course
the underlying cause of that needs to be
corrected but at least can give you
relief as well as
chewing on a clove okay clove will help
numb the tooth okay so you might want to
try that as well
now then we have this thing called
vitamin f now what is vitamin f well
it's a combination of the omega fatty
acids and vitamin f works with calcium
it helps to unload
calcium as one of its functions
so if you look at vitamin d
and vitamin k2 and vitamin f
they all work in this one specific
function of
helping you absorb calcium
transport calcium and then dumping
calcium in the right places so vitamin d
is vital for absorbing calcium from your
intestine to your blood and then vitamin
k2 is important in transporting calcium
to the right areas of the body to the
bone to the teeth
okay and not in the wrong places and
then vitamin f has a function of helping
unload this calcium and uh pushing it
into the tissues so given that
information what foods would have most
of these vitamins well
butter in cod liver oil okay now when
we're talking about butter we're talking
about grass-fed okay and organic
or you can do the ghee
this is loaded with vitamin d
f
vitamin k2 especially and vitamin a okay
and so all these are fat soluble
nutrients or vitamins so butter is
really good for the teeth and gums as a
child
of course with a lot of teeth problems i
craved butter so much i would literally
sit down and consume a stick of butter
without even questioning it i just love
butter and
reflecting back is because i needed
these nutrients okay unfortunately i was
consuming a massive amount of sugar and
refined carbs at the same time
and one point about vitamin c and sugar
is that the chemistry of sugar and
vitamin c is very similar so if you're
consuming all the sugar you're not going
to be able to absorb vitamin c at the
same time okay so
that was my problem and the second food
is cod liver oil now why is cod liver
oil so
good for the teeth and gums and why is
it so unique and different from regular
fish oils okay
well cod liver oil
not only has the omega three fatty acids
that other fish oils have
but it also has vitamin d and vitamin a
whereas other fish oils
usually don't have vitamin d and vitamin
a so it has these two extra things that
are very very good for you it's very
difficult to get vitamin d from your
foods but cod liver oil has a really
good amount of it so with with collard
oil you get these fat soluble vitamins
and this nutrient
which is you can call it a vitamin or
you can just call it a
essential fatty acid combination now you
could also do cod liver you can buy this
in a can it's very fatty it's actually
quite delicious i've recommended it i
will put a link down below if you
haven't tried it you should try it but
it's a really good food so it's it's
actually comes in all the oil as well
but if you consume the whole thing it's
a bit too rich so if you're going to
consume it you have like maybe half of
it and then half the second day but eat
it up within two days because if you
leave it too long it does get a little
fishy okay eggs also have a lot of these
fat soluble nutrients and then greens
okay and i'm talking about leafy greens
that's the vitamin c but you also have
my favorite which is sauerkraut or even
kimchi that's a great source of vitamin
c
as well as probiotics
and vitamin k2
so sauerkraut is really really good for
your teeth and gums
and then as far as the b vitamins go
nutritional yeast is a good source but
you have to realize that your gut also
makes a lot of your b vitamins so if you
don't have
the gut flora or you've had antibiotics
chances are
that could be the reason why you're
deficient in bees so just realize that
these microbes can give you these b
vitamins as well now probably the next
best video for you to watch
would be the one on cod of oil i've done
quite a few but this one is very
interesting check it out
you